Trascrizione: Alessio Politi
Revisore: Michele Gianella
C'era una volta, tanto tempo fa,
il Dio supremo Visnù.
Il quale, vedendo
che c'era disordine sulla Terra,
decise che era giunto il momento
di mettere un po' di ordine.
Ma ebbe il problema di capire
come scendere dalla dimensione divina
alla dimensione terrestre.
Ed essendo lui ovviamente il Dio supremo,
ebbe l'intuizione divina di moltiplicarsi
in dieci forme diverse,
in dieci avatar -
L'avatar è quindi la soluzione
che il dio Visnù ha trovato
per avere il dono dell'ubiquità
e trasportarsi
da una dimensione all'altra.
Vi racconto questa storia
perché, se ci pensate bene,
anche noi oggi viviamo
in una situazione simile
a quella del dio Visnù.
E cioè viviamo in due dimensioni,
in due mondi: il mondo reale
e quello digitale.
Difatti, se penso alla generazione
dei miei genitori,
è stata l'ultima che ha potuto vivere,
almeno per la maggior parte
della loro vita,
soltanto nella dimensione reale.
E poi ci sono io.
In quanto Millennial, ho vissuto in pieno
la nascita del web
e l'arrivo degli smartphone,
ed il bivio dimensionale
che questi hanno generato.
E poi c'è la generazione dei miei figli,
dove praticamente oggi,
anche davanti a un televisore,
cercano di zoomare le immagini con le dita
come se fosse un touchscreen.
Insomma, per la prima volta,
senza precedenti storici
nell'evoluzione dell'uomo,
in sole tre generazioni
è cambiato il mondo.
Incredibile!
Grazie soprattutto ad Internet,
l'Uomo ha avuto accesso
a una quantità di informazioni pazzesca
e alla possibilità di interagire
con il resto del mondo.
Per esempio, noi oggi
possiamo comunicare -
o meglio, possiamo anche perderci
dentro i social network,
facendoci gli affari degli altri.
Oppure possiamo chiacchierare
con degli amici, in videoconference,
che vivono dall'altra parte
del mondo, in Australia.
O meglio ancora,
potremmo visitare un museo
a Pechino, in realtà virtuale.
Insomma, tutto questo
mondo digitale è divertente:
ma come in tutte le cose,
arriva un momento
in cui questo entusiasmo si placa,
e torniamo un po' con i piedi per terra.
E quindi io non voglio giudicare
se tutto questo è giusto o sbagliato.
Ma non possiamo negare il fatto
che tutto il tempo che noi dedichiamo
alla dimensione digitale
ci distrae dalla vita reale.
Non so voi, ma a me sempre più spesso
capita di vivere situazioni del genere.
È importante quindi far sì
che la tecnologia sia a supporto
della vita reale,
senza però soppiantarla.
Sempre più spesso, a me,
più passa il tempo,
più faccio fatica a stare dietro
a questa dimensione digitale.
A volte mi sento bombardato
da mille informazioni
che mi arrivano da tutte le parti.
E non vi nego che, a volte,
mi viene voglia di dire "basta!",
di prendere il telefono
e di lanciarlo contro il muro,
semplicemente per avere
un po' di silenzio.
E allora tutta questa digitalità
è paragonabile a un'onda anomala
che rischia di travolgerci.
Io credo però che noi abbiamo
la possibilità di poterla cavalcare,
e di poterla cavalcare divertendoci.
E sapete qual è la soluzione?
Ma è semplice:
la soluzione è fare un copia incolla
dell'idea del dio Visnù!
E quindi avere, come lui,
il nostro avatar,
per fare ordine nella nostra
dimensione digitale.
Ma prima di parlarvi di avatar,
vorrei condividere una riflessione.
Una riflessione sul fatto che, secondo me,
si è già aperta una nuova era,
che a me piace definire
"Umanesimo Digitale".
Sì, perché rispetto
all'Umanesimo di 600 anni fa,
dove l'Uomo -
dove dopo un periodo buio
durato quasi dieci secoli,
la figura dell'Uomo è stata riportata
al centro del pensiero
filosofico e sociale,
riscoprendo così la valorizzazione
dell'individualità e del talento
di ognuno di noi.
Tutto questo ha innescato
un'accelerazione del progresso,
soprattutto nell'arte,
nella cultura, nella scienza,
per arrivare così fino ai giorni d'oggi
con la cosiddetta "Rivoluzione Digitale".
Bene: oggi, a differenza di 600 anni fa,
io credo che l'Uomo non abbia più bisogno
di essere al centro
di un mondo che gli giri attorno.
Piuttosto abbiamo bisogno
che l'Uomo sia "centrato",
e che lui sappia bene
che è parte, del mondo.
di questo mondo che gira
e girerà comunque, con o senza di lui.
Allora questo "Umanesimo 2.0",
questo nuovo Umanesimo Digitale,
ci mette davanti al fatto
che noi dobbiamo guardare al futuro
da una prospettiva diversa:
una prospettiva collaborativa,
una prospettiva evolutiva,
non più individualista,
non più egocentrica.
Solo così potremo trovare quell'equilibrio
per poter vivere
con il mondo che ci circonda.
E io, sinceramente, da padre
di due meravigliose creature,
mi sento la responsabilità
di poter dar loro,
e alle generazioni future,
un nuovo mezzo, un nuovo strumento
per poter semplicemente
cercare questo equilibrio
e navigare in questo nuovo mare digitale,
che secondo me è tutto da surfare.
E allora permettetemi
di dire "Grazie" al dio Visnù
per averci suggerito
un'idea così brillante
qual è l'avatar, il vero eroe
dell'Umanesimo Digitale.
La rappresentazione pratica,
concreta e immediata
delle soluzioni per mettere ordine
nella nostra dimensione digitale.
Adesso vi spiego meglio cosa intendo io
per avatar, o meglio "Avatarization",
che altro non è che il processo
di convertirci in bit
per poter vivere
nella dimensione digitale.
Avatarization è:
realizzare una perfetta copia digitale,
in 3D, fotorealistica,
della nostra figura.
Un altro io, ma fatto di bit,
che possa muoversi ed interagire
nel mondo digitale
come il mio io reale vive
nella vita quotidiana di tutti i giorni.
E allora viene semplice immaginare
come tutte quelle attività digitali,
che noi svolgiamo nel nostro quotidiano,
possano essere semplificate.
"Avatarization" è anche un progetto
a cui ho impegnato gli ultimi
quattro anni del mio lavoro
e di quello di altri
miei amici millennial -
orgogliosamente tutti italiani, devo dire.
Quattro anni in cui
abbiamo studiato, e analizzato,
tutte le tecnologie di scansione,
individuando poi alla fine
nella tecnologia fotogrammetrica
quella che faceva al nostro caso.
Ma adesso
Vi faccio vedere che cosa abbiamo fatto
in questi ultimi quattro anni,
dove abbiamo provato, iniziato
a sviluppare i primi prototipi:
si era visto prima.
Abbiamo iniziato a costruire
dei propri e veri studi fotogrammetrici.
Ci siamo migliorati,
abbiamo acquisito know-how;
e abbiamo, a un certo punto,
preso questa tecnologia
e l'abbiamo plasmata
sulla forma dell'Uomo.
Ed è venuta fuori una forma a uovo,
simbolo di nascita digitale.
Per arrivare a un body scanner automatico,
che è la porta di accesso
per entrare nel mondo digitale.
Dove, attraverso un semplice clic,
scattiamo da decine e decine
di camere sincronizzate,
una fotografia di noi.
Dopodiché parte un processo,
il processo della creazione dell'avatar,
che è per me magico.
Dove queste immagini ad alta definizione
vengono elaborate da degli algoritmi,
per ricrearci fedelmente
in un ambiente 3D.
Dove manteniamo le nostre informazioni,
che sono uniche,
e creiamo il nostro avatar.
Il risultato è fotorealistico:
ha il colore della nostra pelle;
è misurabile; ha la nostra morfologia.
Poi c'è la parte di vestizione.
Ed infine inseriamo
uno scheletro digitale,
per potergli dare il dono del movimento,
per poterlo muovere.
Ed ecco che abbiamo creato
il nostro avatar.
E adesso, probabilmente,
vi starete chiedendo:
"Si ok Billy, va bene;
ma ancora non abbiamo capito
come l'avatar può semplificarci la vita,
e mettere un po' di ordine".
E allora permettetemi di mostrarvi
qualche esempio, semplice e veloce,
di quello che ci siamo immaginati,
ma sul quale già oggi noi stiamo lavorando
per far sì che presto diventi realtà.
Il primo campo d'applicazione è il gaming.
Sì, perché con il nostro avatar
noi possiamo divertirci,
possiamo entrare nel vivo di un gioco.
Ancora oggi, a distanza ormai
di più di 20 anni,
solo i grandi campioni,
solo chi ha i piedi buoni
può divertirsi con il proprio avatar.
Bene, io sinceramente i piedi buoni
non ce li ho mai avuti,
ma il mio avatar si: guardate qui.
Sono riuscito ad entrare
in un gioco, ho giocato,
mi sono permesso di giocare
in una delle squadre più forti al mondo,
che è il Barcellona,
e sono anche riuscito a fare un gol
al novantesimo minuto contro l'Inter,
che è la mia squadra rivale da sempre.
Un altro esempio, un altro campo
d'applicazione è la moda.
Nel mondo del fashion, grazie all'avatar,
noi possiamo semplificare
il processo di acquisto on line.
Sì, perché abbiamo detto
che l'avatar ha le nostre misure,
la nostra morfologia,
le nostre informazioni;
e quindi ci può dare quella sicurezza
che quando acquistiamo su un e-commerce,
sappiamo che quel prodotto
è della taglia giusta.
E quindi andiamo a risolvere
il problema dei resi,
sia per noi ma anche per le aziende.
Ma i vantaggi non finiscono qui,
perché per esempio potremmo condividere
le nostre informazioni
con il nostro sarto o brand preferito,
per commissionargli dei capi su misura.
O meglio ancora,
l'avatar può diventare
il nostro personal shopper,
e provare per noi dei capi 3D
che corrispondono a dei capi reali.
Facendo così,
noi abilitiamo le aziende di moda
a poter iniziare a pensare
di produrre direttamente sul venduto,
perché andiamo a ottimizzare
tutti quei processi
come la prototipazione,
la produzione, la logistica.
Rendendo il sistema della moda
molto più sostenibile,
non solo in termini economici
ma soprattutto ambientali.
Adesso vi mostro cosa ha provato
il mio avatar per me.
Ecco - ah no, scusate:
questo è un capo
che voleva provarsi mia moglie,
ma dato che lei non ha
ancora il suo avatar,
le ho prestato il mio.
Invece questo è un capo si da uomo,
adatto ad un'occasione
come questa, per esempio.
Ok.
Allora, adesso passiamo invece
a un altro campo d'applicazione.
Un campo d'applicazione
che riguarda la salute dell'uomo,
come per esempio il wellness.
Sì perché, attraverso
più scansioni nel tempo,
noi possiamo monitorare
come cambia il nostro corpo.
Vedete, chi mi conosce lo sa:
a me piace mangiare.
E io, qualche mese fa,
ero sinceramente un po' in sovrappeso.
Allora ho fatto la scansione,
ho condiviso il mio avatar
con la palestra, il personal trainer,
con il nutrizionista,
il quale ha elaborato i miei dati
e mi ha creato un percorso di lavoro.
Sono migliorato, ho rifatto la scansione,
abbiamo messo a confronto
i due modelli, i due avatar.
Siamo andati a vedere
dove sono migliorato e dove no,
e hanno potuto riottimizzarmi
il mio piano di lavoro.
E poi siamo andati oltre:
abbiamo fatto una previsione
di come potrei diventare.
E non vi nego che per me
è stimolante tutto questo,
perché io tutte le mattine
guardo il mio avatar bello del futuro
e piuttosto che dormire
ancora mezz'oretta,
prendo e me ne vado a correre.
Un altro campo è il campo medicale.
Nel campo medicale, avere un avatar
è avere una cartella clinica
che ha la nostra forma,
le nostre informazioni,
la nostra morfologia,
le nostre immagini ad alta risoluzione.
E quindi viene semplice immaginare
come noi potremmo condividere
tutti questi dati
con gli ospedali, con i medici,
con le Università.
Potremmo contribuire a creare
un database di corpi digitali,
che corrisponda alla popolazione reale,
per aiutare la ricerca, no?
Pensiamo anche a campi come l'ortopedia,
dove andiamo a togliere il gesso
grazie a tutori e protesi stampati in 3D.
L'avatar può diventare,
per esempio per i fisioterapisti,
uno strumento per effettuare
check-up posturali,
per monitorare dei percorsi
di riabilitazione.
O in campo dermatologico, per esempio,
può diventare uno strumento
di prevenzione,
perché grazie alla scansione
potrà fare una mappatura dei nei.
Magari, il nostro stesso avatar
ci potrà indicare se quel neo
è un possibile melanoma,
e noi potremmo andare
a prendere tempestivamente
l'appuntamento con il dermatologo.
Insomma, questi sono
soltanto alcuni esempi
di quello che ci siamo immaginati,
ma che è già un work in progress.
Ma i campi di applicazione
sono potenzialmente infiniti,
perché tutto quello che viene studiato,
progettato, o realizzato sull'uomo,
ha un senso se pensiamo all'avatar.
Ma cerchiamo ora
di immaginare un po' più in là:
in un mondo fatto di tecnologie
sempre più veloci,
coinvolgenti, complesse -
tecnologie che sono tra di noi
o che stanno arrivando,
come la realtà virtuale,
la realtà aumentata, il 5G,
la blockchain, l'Intelligenza Artificiale.
Tutte tecnologie che possono, secondo me,
dare i superpoteri al nostro avatar.
E magari un domani il nostro avatar
potrà, non so, prenotarci un ristorante
indicando al ristoratore
il nostro piano alimentare.
Oppure prenotarci un viaggio al mare
e acquistare per noi
un'attrezzatura sportiva,
creata su misura per noi.
O meglio ancora, potremo
parlare con il nostro avatar
come se fosse un vero
e proprio assistente,
e magari lui stesso
potrà rispondere alle mail per noi.
Pensa che bello!
Insomma, sinceramente io credo che,
così come 25 anni fa del cellulare
non sapevamo esattamente cosa farcene,
così fra molto meno di 25 anni
ognuno di noi avrà
un altro sè digitale, un avatar,
per risparmiare tempo, denaro ed energia.
Spero quindi che voi possiate approcciare
questa dimensione digitale
con più serenità,
consapevoli che l'avatar sarà
un compagno di viaggio
che vive nel digitale,
per mettere ordine
e per cavalcare quest'onda come non mai.
Insomma, per avere più tempo
per la vita reale
e, perché no, vivere meglio
il momento presente.
Grazie.
(Applausi)